♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to Correctshuns
for the week of August 9th.
We missed you guys,
and we're looking forward
to getting right into it.
I -- very strange for me,
but I want to start off
by apologizing to Donald Trump
for an error I made in
this week's Closer Look.
We talked about how when
he was a USFL team owner,
the USFL sued the NFL
for an antitrust violation,
and they sued
for $1.7 million --
or a billion dollars.
I guess it must have been
$1.7 billion.
And they received a dollar.
They were awarded a dollar.
And we sort of made fun
of Donald Trump
for the fact that
he was awarded a dollar.
But I made a mistake
because in antitrust cases,
damages are tripled.
So in the end, they got $3.
So you are good at business.
I referenced one of
my favorite shows, "Hot Ones,"
where people eat hot,
progressively hotter
chicken wings
and said no one would do
that show twice.
Some people have done it twice.
Steve-O has done it twice,
of course.
Eric Andre has done it twice.
So I apologize
that I got that wrong.
I also said that as soon
as I did "Hot Ones,"
the next interview I did was
with Terry Gross at "Fresh Air,"
because I wanted to do
an interview
where I wasn't worried
that I'd have to excuse myself
because I was gonna
[bleep] my pants.
And someone said,
"Hey, those are --
you do Terry Gross
over the phone,
so you wouldn't
have to excuse yourself."
I think even if I was
on the phone with someone,
I wouldn't just like, [bleep].
I wouldn't take advantage
of the fact
that we were on the phone
to be like,
"I'm gonna [bleep] my pants."
But it is true
that you do "Fresh Air,"
you do not
do "Fresh Air" in person
unless you're
Seth [bleep] Meyers, pal.
You guys should just
start doing apologies.
Didn't want to hold up
an art card, guys,
'cause it's -- we talked
about my fingernails.
I don't even want to
hold up my hands.
They're bad.
You guys said I have terrible --
I needed a manicure, and I tried
really hard over the hiatus
to stop chewing my nails,
and it didn't go well.
My goal is to
have really beautiful hands,
should we ever hold up,
as Shoemaker calls it,
Lady Emmy.
And...
But the one thing
I'm not gonna do
is what all my colleagues
in the late night field --
I will not use a hand model.
You think when Kimmel
holds up an album,
you think those are his hands?
Grow up.
We mentioned the song "Gasolina"
and said it was a Pitbull song.
This was before the break,
and it's just been
a relentless two weeks
of people telling us
it's a Daddy Yankee song.
My favorite phrasing of it was,
"What gringo on your staff
thought it was Pitbull?"
Se llama Alex Baze.
[ Speaking in Spanish ]
Pitbull is on a remix
of "Gasolina."
And Baize is always
about the remixes.
When there's a new remix
of a popular song,
we don't even expect
to see him in the office.
He loves to take an original
and just remix it
and make it better,
unless it's one of his jokes.
We talked about Ronnie Jackson,
who was the president's doctor.
Dr. Ronnie is now a congressman.
And we put up a key
where he was playing a flute,
and this is another one
where a lot of people got to us.
He was holding
the flute to the left.
Flutes only go to the right.
I did not know that,
and I don't
want to know any more.
I will take your word for it
and let's end it there.
I can't believe we've got
to put up this graphic again.
This is now a month ago.
We put up a graphic of me
getting a drive-through
appendectomy.
Alex, can we put it up
real quick?
And originally,
first thing we heard was,
that's not where
the appendectomy scar was.
The next thing we heard was,
you should be wearing a mask.
Next thing we heard was,
you're driving the wrong way
through the drive-through,
based on the arrow.
And then finally someone said,
"Why do you have a guitar?"
And like,
we've talked about this,
that the graphics team,
they like to get in trouble.
They're just like,
little stinkers.
And I heard this
and I went down.
I'm like, "Why did you guys
put a guitar in there?
You know, I don't play guitar,
right?"
And they were like,
"Yeah, we know."
I was like, "Also, did you know
flutes only go to the right?"
"Uh-huh."
Talked about that if Trump --
this is based on the whole
Four Seasons Hotel
and Four Seasons landscaping.
We had a joke,
if Trump told Rudy
to do something
at a Waldorf Astoria,
he would do it
at a Walmart in Astoria.
There's no Walmart in Astoria.
I wrote that joke. I checked.
I saw, I knew
there was no Walmart in Astoria.
Still told it.
Knitting.
We talked about
a grandmother saying,
"Hey, it's knitting time.
Put down that 'Grand Theft Auto'
and help me crochet
this blanket."
Well, knitting and crocheting
are two very different things,
I've been told.
And I want to read a comment
someone had about it.
I'm not going to
read the first sentence.
I'm gonna go back and pick up
the first sentence.
Someone wrote,
"Knitting and crocheting
are completely different,
and that lady is working
a sleeve or a sock.
Definitely not an Afghan.
Definitely not crochet.
Sloppy work, guys."
The first sentence was,
"Are you [bleep] kidding me?"
Definitely not lining up
with my stereotype
of the knitting community.
It's like, watching
A Closer Look.
The [bleep]?
Talked about somebody wearing
one of the flying squirrel suits
cliff diving.
I was told that
would be base diving.
We talked about Jeff Bezos
jetting to space,
jetting off to space.
Someone said you don't jet
to space, you rocket to space.
And you can [bleep] off
to space.
Oh, someone said that, hey,
that during a correction,
sometimes I hold
my arm like this
and it looks like
I'm going to dislocate it,
and that is what
I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to like put
the discomfort here
to distract from this.
So we have these
jackal mugs we've been making.
These are not available
in the NBC store,
because NBC hates money.
And so this one, we put up,
and these are just jackal paws
that we found online.
Let's look at it
real quick again.
I didn't realize they were
two different ones.
I guess this is --
that's the front of a jackal,
and that's a back of the jackal.
And nobody commented,
but then this
was the updated one,
and then someone said, "Hey,
I didn't mind the first time,
but...
that wouldn't be how
a jackal would type,
because that would be
one front paw and one back paw.
So that would imply that
the jackal's lying
on its side typing."
Okay.
I love that someone's like,
"I'll go with you on this
for a jackal,
but come on, dude.
That's stupid."
I got to confess,
I'm like, ashamed of myself.
Went day drinking with Lorde --
amazing, so much fun,
and then we did these paintings.
We just tried to
recreate the cover
of one of her albums
in these paintings,
and then we did, on the
"Late Night" Twitter account,
basically said,
who painted it better?
And Lorde won.
Not like a giant,
but like 53% to 47%.
And then I'm deeply ashamed,
because then I did a second poll
on the Sea Captain Polls
Twitter account,
which I thought would have
less Lorde fans.
And I phrased it in a way
that I really wanted people
to vote for me, and I did win,
but I won by less than Lorde won
in the first vote.
So I just want to say right now,
Lorde won fair and square
and I apologize
for trying to rig it.
I'm ashamed of myself.
We talked about
honey-baked ham stores
and how I park across
the street from them,
because I can't believe
there are people just walking in
and buying a whole-ass ham.
A couple of things --
one, a lot of people defending
honey-baked hams
being delicious,
saying I was
out of bounds on that.
But then someone wrote this
about whole-ass hams.
"Correction -- technically,
whole-ass ham is redundant,
because ham comes
from an area of the pig
that could arguably
be considered its ass,
and also it would only be
a half-ass ham,
because it's only one
half of the pig's ass."
That's poetry.
Like, I read that
and I was like, this is why.
This is why we do this.
Because someday,
you're just gonna be
scrolling, scrolling through
you know, a YouTube comment,
and you're gonna read
this beautiful sentence.
Two sentences.
Also,
I feel like we're
pretty committed to
"Late Night with Seth Meyers,"
but...
I'd call this show
"half-ass ham."
Alright.
I think that's about everything.
And we'll see
you guys next week.